this week were taken a real classic city
car out for a spin for over 30 years
this peppy little Italian favorite has
been a mainstay on the streets of Europe
the Fiat Panda is now in its third
incarnation
her car tester Stefan Hinson says it was
easy to find his vehicle thanks to the
navigation system it's easy to remove it
from the car and then you can use it to
find your way on foot he says time to
see how it does on the road it smells
there's lots of glass in the little car
and good visibility in all directions a
big plus in the city customers can
choose between a diesel motor version
one that runs on natural gas or one of
two gasoline driven models we're testing
the smaller but more powerful one be
0.98 v-twin air
thanks to a turbocharger the two
cylinder motor ponies up 63 kilowatts of
power despite having less than a liter
of displacement that's not enough to
turn the Panda into a spreader though it
takes the subcompact over 11 seconds to
hit 100 kilometers an hour from a dead
stop
but Fiat at least claims it's economical
the car maker says it burns just over 4
liters of fuel per hundred clicks on the
highway Stefan says that response is
very sluggish when you step on the gas
and that the 63 kilowatts of power don't
really kick in until you hit around 2000
rpms but driving like this he says will
certainly affect the manufacturer's
promised low fuel consumption claims but
let's be fair after all the Panda was
never meant to compete on the racetrack
its rounded corners and friendly
exterior I'm meant to attract buyers who
are looking for a more cuddly ride no
sharp edges here the entire car is a
study in curves even the geometric
shapes in the grille running lights and
bumpers are organic
the first generation of pandas one heart
says boxes on wheels and the latest
version is still very boxy but every
corner is rounded off and with the Panda
design doesn't get in the way of
functionality the trunk has 225 cubic
liters of space and lowering the rear
seats expands that to 870 litres Stefan
says that the Panda provides a very
smooth ride once it gets rolling putting
the car in city mode makes the steering
wheel more responsive he says the Panda
also has a stop-start system and the
gears shift very smoothly although
there's plenty of plastic in the
interior to cut costs the Panda doesn't
feel cheap the dashboard elements fit
the cars overall rounded personality a
bare-bones version of the Panda sells in
Germany for less than ten thousand euros
a safe space all the seats have narrow
back rests a good idea but a seating
test shows that a taller than average
driver makes for a very tight squeeze
and back
there's enough Headroom that adults that
have to sit in the rear probably won't
enjoy it for long in short says Stefan
the Fiat Panda drives well it's agile
and small enough that finding parking in
the city shouldn't pose much of a
problem the perfect car for students for
young people he says if it wasn't for
that little question about fuel
consumption then this their split
father's off there